[Music]
all right coming up on 6 26 it's a real
tell
all your friends alert for southbound
i-15 drivers heading to california
this afternoon the nevada department of
transportation starts
a repaving project on the freeway
between jean and prim
you're going to be down to two lanes
between 2 p.m and 6 p.m
then down to one lane from 6 p.m to 6
a.m
now it might not be as bad as it may
sound for a couple of reasons first
going to be no work on weekends and that
includes the upcoming memorial day
weekend actually working to be suspended
until june
2nd and the project is planned as a
so-called moving operation
two miles at a time that's all they're
going to be doing now indot says
this nearly 11 million dollar 16-mile
project is going to take 100 work days
but at the same time they're saying they
want done before the end of the year so
anyway they say plan on 10-minute delays
through the work zones but man if you've
got the option
to completely avoid the weekday work
hours of 2 pm to 6 a.m
probably not a bad idea you can go over
the closures and the online version of
this story at eightnewsnow.com when you
click traffic then driving me crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com